also heute ist ja das was auch sie
verharmlosen feiern nennen und das
mitmachen ein das haben sie nicht eine
party das ist auch nicht das tun wir
nicht das sind massen besorgnisse und
man schiebt sich daten oder crystal meth
in die adern und dann fallen alle
hemmungen und dann ist das total geiles
gefühl
pflastersteine auf menschen zu werfen
oder oder wir haben das ja nicht nur bei
polizeibeamten feuerwehrleute werden
angegriffen
arbeiter samariter bund wird angegriffen
ordnungsamt schon lange also alle die so
etwas ähnliches wie eine uniform an
haben sind repräsentanten dieses
verhassten staates und den müssen wir es
mal besorgen und in ein paar auf die
nuss geben würden so ungefähr stellt
sich das in den köpfen
fakt ist dass in diesem land an jedem
wochenende polizisten passion werden
das ist fakt und fakt ist dass man der
polizei pauschal vorwirft sie hat
strukturelle probleme rassistische
probleme es werden gesetze gemacht wie
man gegen die polizei auch mit verbänden
vorgehen hat berlin ja
antidiskriminierungsgesetz das sind doch
die punkte über die wir uns unterhalten
müssen und nicht wie toll wir sind und
wie schön wir also schon im griff haben
wir haben ja verständigung mit den
haftbefehlen und die setzen wir im
vollzug und dann machen wir auch schnell
urteile die letzten urteile aus hamburg
beim gipfel sind jetzt gerade in den
letzten tagen gefallen da konnte man
natürlich niemand mehr identifiziert
werden dann haben wir da die freisprüche
kassierers während in stuttgart nicht
anders was wir uns passieren damit das
nächstes wochenende oder besten nie mehr
passiert heinz buschkowsky in dem wir
schauen wo
wann ist praktisch hapert und uns hapert
es nicht an schönrederei also das ist
halt was wir und ihr könnt hier wirklich
aus dem kleister gehen wenn das so ist
dass das alles so ein mist was in berlin
gemacht wurde kann nicht bestehen was
fehlt warum schickt er in seiner
polizisten war jetzt wurde in stuttgart
ist war jetzt frankfurt sie reden muss
heißt natürlich dass die justiz schnell
reagieren muss wir müssen zu anklagen
kommen und wir müssen dann zu gerichten
kommen die auch urteile fällen und da
nutzt mir die die 15 monatige strafe auf
bewährung zwei jahre später über hawking
ein paar wären jetzt barbie verfolgen
und wir werden schauen was da hinten an
sache wirklich rauskommt ist das
schnellere und ob der straße gestellt
wird ist nichts wenn wir die sprüche
ganz konkret ganz konkret ich verstehe
nicht was in stuttgart los ist bei uns
in hamburg ist es so teilweise dass die
zivilpolizisten einfach nur eine uniform
anziehen müssen und mit streife laufen
weil personalmangel herrscht
ich weiß nicht wenn es so viele bewerber
gibt warum gibt es dann so viele
überstunden und klar es muss aufgestockt
werden die ausbildung muss besser werden
es genügt nicht
anderthalb stunden die woche polizei
sportdienst das ist lächerlich
ich habe die leute kommen dann zu mir
und beschweren sich dass sie da nichts
lernen oder nicht fit bleiben und ja
insgesamt muss die stimmung einfach der
asylpolitik darf der polizei den rücken
fallen und generell muss man anderes
bild in der öffentlichkeit schaffen was
die polizei angeht